à mons ou alors tu es parti pendant
quinze jours soit déserté bain de minuit
à paris la meinau résidence chez moi jen
des grands jours était avant tout est
noir mais ne t'ai pas de [ __ ] la
vacance de carrément caramel chocolat
était calme alors que le pays était à
bout stick la caisse qui se concentre
pour 50 dans mon enfance l'eau claire de
soleil et la plage dans les familles la
bouffe c'est st maur qui grandissent ans
étaient invités
tu regardes ce qu'elle a dans les jours
de la semaine
écoutez le seul officier mardi sonne la
boue mais la demande a tendance à vous
êtes mariés mais mon préféré
ouch c'est quoi ça c'est en anglais mais
on peut comme steely dan et c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre s'agit donc du début à la
fin la fin a vraiment écouté il faut il
faut tout faire d'ailleurs sur sa selle
et marvin gaye alors y'a film classe ou
est très douce qui suit et la musique
répétitive vrai là c'est pas répétitif
du tout cela en musique un film produit
par l'internaute à francis coppola des
personnes tonnerre 1
et puis voilà il ya premier morceau qui
est très très bien sans son nouveau rôle
le produit offert la première phase elle
s'appelle si elle veut pas vrai alors ça
c'est bien on peut me montrer un peu
comme ça le montre le général à la
france tienne cet orgue inrets avec ma
photo sur la pochette
voilà tout le monde le reconnaît
d'ailleurs baguenault et ses compléments
latin c'est complètement débile atteint
maintenant ces compléments celia cruz
les tam-tams le bongoland rooms les
[ __ ] derrière il ya tout mais là il
ya le nouveau disque intérieur du centre
noir dont gerry harrison voilà qui est
très bien il ya un morceau patronat
voilà alors si c'est thierry harrison
qu'un jour où le bar vous bien c'est
1,56 à les gones super convaincant ce
match où je n'aurais pas su par plus
tueur est décontenancé la fin de l'année
oui mais traite avec un fouet et
maintenant ah bon tu donneras oui mais
là une petite semaine au mois d'août sa
merci et cela passe et qu'on l'ait le la
couleur sa part déjà ah bon je peins
dans certains endroits vendredi 0 et le
premier mais tu veux des filets de peine
je crois que je retourne à cuba d'accord
je retourne à cuba le 10 juin
mais je reste sur la glace je préfère
tuer le père
c'est un bisou les plus choqués
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu